ship in seven years as almost is all of
these games are structured worlds with
well-defined rules each involved
strategies and potential payoffs when we
put money on games the outcome affects
us therefore we care about the odds the
understanding of odds or chance leads to
probability theory the founding father
of this subject had a serious stake in
understanding the outcome of a game of
dice car Donna was an Italian
mathematician with a well known gambling
addiction he wrote letters in which he
bragged about his ability to beat his
friends his trick was to place his bets
using his ideas from mathematics his
breakthrough was a method of calculating
a certainty or probability of some
random event such as rolling Snake Eyes
let's pause for a moment and think about
the physics of dice there are two
reasons why a dice roll is unpredictable
or random the first is symmetry dice are
designed to be symmetrical unlike an egg
which is asymmetrical always falling
predictably onto its broadside dice are
balanced so they do not favor aside the
second is mixture each time we roll a
dice tiny changes in the initial
position and velocity of the dice are
amplified as it bounces along its path
the unpredictability comes from not
knowing the exact initial speed position
and direction of the toss this results
in a powerful property card on O notice
every outcome is equally likely this
allowed him to calculate the probability
by developing what's now called a
probability space first he counts all
the possible outcomes then he defines
the event in question such as rolling a
1 which can occur in one way the
probability is then found by dividing
the event by all possible events which
in this case works out to 1/6 realize
the cold calculating logic here there is
no such thing as a lucky number no
divine intervention the probability of
rolling any number is exactly 1/6 the
same logic applies when we roll multiple
dice imagine he needed to know the
probability of rolling a pair such as
Snake Eyes first it counts the size of
the sample space with two dice rolls
there are 36 possible outcomes 6 times 6
then he counts the number of ways you
can roll a pair there are 6 different
pairs so 6 divided by 36 is the
probability of rolling a pair also 1/6
this simple yet powerful idea allowed
cardano's to bed according to the true
odds while his opponent's place their
bets based on hunches and lucky numbers
remember this works with multiple tosses
imagine we needed to know the odds of
rolling three ones so
first we figure out the size of the
sample space for three dice this is 6
times 6 times 6 or 216 there is only one
way to roll 3 ones so the probability is
1 divided by 216 this was the trick it
was not based on magic but mathematics
years later two more Italians Pascal and
Fermat refine cardona's idea while they
were pondering the outcome of sequences
of random events such as multiple coin
flips
consider the following imagine two rooms
inside each room is a switch in one room
there is a man who flips the switch
according to a coin flip if he lands
heads the switch is on tails the switch
is off in the other room a woman
switches her light based on the blind
guess she tries to simulate randomness
without a coin then we start a clock and
they make each switch in unison now the
interesting question can you determine
which light bulb is being switched by a
coin flip the answer is yes but how the
first step is to keep track of each
sequence of events one equals on 0
equals off
the trick is to think about the
properties of each sequence rather than
looking for specific patterns first we
may try to count the number of ones and
zeros in each sequence this is close but
not enough since they will both seem
fairly even the answer is to count
sequences of numbers such as runs of
three consecutive switches a true random
sequence will be equally likely to
contain every sequence of any length
this is called the frequency stability
property and is demonstrated by this
uniform looking graph the forgery now is
obvious
humans favor certain sequences when they
make guesses resulting in uneven
patterns such as we see here one reason
this happens is because we make the
mistake of thinking certain outcomes are
less random than others but realize
there is no such thing as a lucky number
and no such thing as a lucky sequence if
we flip a coin 10 times it is equally
likely to come up all heads all tails or
any other sequence you can think of